this is the key which opens the door for
future growth and stability that's the
CEO of lucid a company you probably
haven't heard of even though it was
valued at 24 billion dollars last year
and the key he's talking about is a spec
or a special purpose acquisition company
from mid-2020 to 2021 spax were one of
the hottest Investments on Wall Street
making up the majority of U.S IPOs but
by May of 2021 activity had sharply
declined that month there were about 125
fewer IPOs than there had been three
months before it's really been stunning
how quickly it's come to an end in the
past year and a half so what went wrong
a special purpose acquisition company or
SPAC exists to merge with a private
company and take it public it's an
alternative to a traditional IPO here's
how they work first Founders raise money
from investors and set up a shell
company which they then take public with
an IPO or initial public offering that's
the SPAC then they search for a private
company to merge with but there is a
deadline usually two years from here
there are two possibilities if the SPAC
doesn't find a company it's liquidated
shareholders receive their money back
and Founders lose the millions it took
to set up the company if this back does
find a Target they merge taking back
company public the company replaces this
back in the stock market and investors
can now buy shares but why would
companies want to skip a traditional IPO
you can make business projections you
can communicate to the public and do
things that you normally can't in a
traditional initial public offering the
method gained popularity and in December
2020 and January 2021 many specs were
raising billions of dollars they tapped
into trendy businesses
like electric vehicles satellites and
flying taxis and they were very
attractive to individual investors who
looked out and said I want to own the
next Tesla I want to find these startups
that are going to make me a lot of money
the buzz was also fueled by social media
star Founders who posted their
accomplishments online so what would
happen is a SPAC would announce a merger
and then creators like tremath
palhapatia or others would promote the
merger on CNBC it's a business that I
think will become extremely valuable
they would tweet about it and individual
investors would jump on the bandwagon
and these things would start trending
the hype helped Fuel stock price gains
for companies like Lucid Virgin Galactic
and Nikola and spacfone Founders
generated average returns of more than
eight times their investment in 2020.
there is a period in time that I tracked
where every single company that
announced a SPAC merger shares of that
spec went up but the flood of
fundraising and ipoing didn't last after
a record month when spax raised 36
billion dollars things took a turn even
academics journalists people like me
were writing articles saying like this
won't end well because we have a lot of
data showing this historically never
ends well but people weren't really
listening in that moment so just became
like a firestorm one of the two reasons
behind the fall was that a few electric
vehicle startups had promised success in
their business projections misleading
their investors take a rival which sells
electric buses it said it would go from
zero Revenue to 14 billion dollars in
just three years arrivals president
explained the projections by saying that
2021 was a turning point for Rapid
adoption of electric vehicles in many
cases what was under the hood was not
very pretty and not as bold and like
spicy as people thought at the time of
the merger announcement so there is a
lot of bad information frankly out there
too that was pushing people to jump on
the bandwagon this caught the eye of
regulators and led to the second reason
behind the fall in April the SEC warned
that some spacs might have to restate
their financial results because at the
end of the day we need to ensure that
investors are protected both reasons
spooked investors share prices declined
and many investors withdrew their money
rather than hold on to shares of
startups after they completed spec deals
after the summer of 2021 companies
started to think twice before going
public with us back a lot of companies
are really second guessing whether they
want to do spec deals as well so that
kind of positive effect that made specs
boom is now working in Reverse where now
the negative connotation is making
everyone second guess things activity
stayed at a relatively low consistent
rate for the next year then in March
2022 the SEC proposed a set of
regulations that would make it harder
for spax to raise money from investors
and execute mergers IBS staff for
recommendations about how we might
update our roles so that investors are
better informed about the fees the costs
the conflicts that may exist with these
specs the goal of the regulations to
make companies disclose information more
like a traditional IPO but a lot of the
damage had already been done by that
point that sentiment though that
Regulators are stepping in and going to
regulate these things more that's also
had a chilling effect for sure in the
stock market by May about 90 percent of
specs that merged during the 2020 boom
were trading below their initial listing
price analysts estimate that if the
current pace of mergers continues a
large percentage of the roughly 280
specs that have deadlines in the first
quarter of 2023 won't find a match
recently SPAC activity is at a low back
activity is basically drawn to a
standstill in July no new specs raise
money early last year there were
basically tens of new specs every week
the market along with the broader stock
market and market for newly public
companies is definitely reversed a lot
after interest rates climbed in the
spring speculative Investments are
losing favor and valuations for
companies that went public through specs
may continue to come down from the highs
of 2021.